(moans)
(intense music)
- I'm YB, and today we're doing
a Manuel Burrito challenge.
They sent out an email at work,
"Who wants to do it?" and all
my coworkers nominated me.
And so here I am.
- Hi, I'm Carlos.
I'm gonna be making the
Manuel Special burrito.
It's our biggest burrito
here at El Tepeyac.
My grandfather Manuel came up with it.
What the story is, is that Cal State,
when it had a football
team, long time ago,
they wanted a really big
burrito for the full players,
and he had nothing on the menu.
So what happened was, he
went to the back, he said,
"No, I'm gonna cup 'em
with something real quick."
So he came up with this
burrito, the Manuel Special,
and it's been on the menu ever since.
(giggles)
- Oh my.
This is the size of a baby.
- [Woman] Three,
two,
one.
- Okay.
I'm just gonna start from the corner.
It doesn't even wrap
around the whole thing.
Mm!
It's not gonna be a
classy eating challenge.
Get this giant bite.
It's really good.
It has a lotta rice.
They put three scoops of rice in it,
and rice is usually what
makes you full first,
so that's gonna be the challenge.
(edgy rock music)
That's kinda like 1/3.
I'm thinking if I should take a break,
but if I do I might get
fuller, so I don't know.
I'm almost halfway.
Definitely getting harder.
In the beginning, I was
just eating it really fast,
and now I'm slowing down a bit.
I feel really gross right now.
I just can't take more cheese and rice,
so we're gonna switch
over to my coworker Ken,
(giggles) and he's going
to finish the burrito.
- Now that I'm sitting down,
it's way bigger than I initially thought.
I didn't eat lunch, so this is fine.
This will be my lunch.
And then what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna work by sections.
At this point, we just wanna finish it.
(light, cheesy music)
- My hand is refusing to go to my mouth.
We have ten minutes left.
I think I'm gonna need to tap out.
- It looks so much bigger
once you're on top of it,
but I only have like eight minutes.
I eat rice, pork, and
guac on the regular, so.
(strong rock music)
Trying to imagine that I'm really hungry.
(buzzer sounds)
(bell dings)
Done.
- We're all dying right now.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
I don't feel like a winner.
- [YB and Ken] But we finished.
- Yeah, we finished it.
- Yeah.
- So that's the most important part.